6-Mute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6-minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Beth. How old are you, Beth?
That's a very personal question, Neil.
Sorry, I didn't mean to be rude.
Anyway, at least you're not a centenarian.
Someone who's lived to be a hundred years old.
Are you saying I look a hundred? That's even rude.
Sorry, Beth, no. It's just that with advances in modern medicine, people are living longer
and longer.
There was a time when living to a hundred seemed impossible. But in 2021, the United Nations
Population Division estimated there to be over half a million centenarians worldwide.
And that number is set to rise.
So how do you live to a hundred? And what could life be like in your twilight years?
A phrase meaning your old age or the last years of your life.
That's what we'll be discussing in this programme and of course we'll be learning some useful
new vocabulary too.
But first I have a question for you, Beth. In 2022, the world's oldest certified person
died aged 119. But which country was she from? Was it A, Switzerland, B, Italy or C, Japan?
Hmm, I think the answer is Japan.
Okay, Beth, we'll find out the answer at the end of the programme.
Of all the many factors for long life, such as diet, exercise and keeping active, human
relationships are among the most important. People who are more connected with others and
have warmer relationships live longer and stay healthier. And according to psychiatrist
Robert Waldinger, talking here with the BBC World Service programme, the inquiry, those
relationships don't necessarily have to be with humans.
Introverts actually find having a lot of people around stressful. So they might only need
one or two close people. And that's all they need, that's all they want and that's just
fine for them. So one size doesn't fit all when it comes to how many relationships you
need to have a healthy life. It doesn't have to be done with another human. We know that
pets provide us with a great deal of comfort and joy and pets can calm us down.
Whether you're a shy introvert or noisy extrovert, what counts is friendship. Be that with
a human or a pet. Different things work for different people. So Dr Waldinger says it's
not one size fits all. A phrase meaning something which is suitable for everyone or every
purpose. So far we've mentioned the importance of diet, exercise and friendship, but some
people want more radical ways of defying death and staying young. Dr Neer Barzoli, director
of the American Federation for Aging Research, has developed three scenarios in his work
with Centenarians in the US. The first scenario called Doreen Gray, after the fictional character
who didn't age, involves delaying the aging process. Here's Dr. Barzoli explaining more
to BBC World Service Programme, the inquiry. The second scenario is what we call the Wolverine
or the fountain of youth, taking old people and make them young. This is very, very hard.
This will be the most complex things we can do. And the third scenario, and this is a very
exciting scenario, and we have some evidence that it works, is the Peter Pan scenario.
Peter Pan didn't grow old. The idea that you'll take people when they're 20 or 30 and give
them a treatment every few months or every year, and you'll basically erase their aging
and let them age very, very slowly, which also will mean probably that it'll pass their
115-year maximal potential lifespan. All Dr. Barzoli's treatments are aimed at extending
lifespan. The length of time someone is normally expected to live. His second treatment, making
someone who is old younger, is called the fountain of youth, a legendary source of magical
water that keeps anyone who drinks it young forever.
Dr. Barzoli's third treatment involves slowing down the aging process so much that people hardly
age at all. This treatment is called Peter Pan, after the fictional boy who never grew up,
and is connected to another idiom, Peter Pan Syndrome, which describes an immature person
who has reached adulthood but refuses to take on adult responsibilities. But which country
was the certified oldest person in the world from? That was your question, Neil, and I
guessed Japan, but was I right?
You were correct! Kaneda Tanaka was born on the Japanese island of Kyushu. She lived
to 119, the oldest human ever recorded, and her secret, playing chess, eating chocolate
and drinking coffee. Okay, let's recap the vocabulary we've learned from this program
about centenarians, people aged 100 years or more.
Your twilight years are your old age.
The phrase one size fits all means suitable for everyone or every purpose.
A lifespan is the length of time someone is normally expected to live.
The legendary fountain of youth produces magical water so that anyone who drinks it
lives forever.
And finally, the phrase Peter Pan Syndrome describes an adult who refuses to grow up.
Once again, our six minutes are up.
Join us again soon for more useful vocabulary here at 6 Minute English. Goodbye for now.
Bye.